appel un véritable plan national et
européen contre le trafic de drogue euh
tribune et réflexion qui viennent
nourrir notre commission d'enquête sur
l'impact du narcotrafic avant d'aller
plus loin je vais comme il est de
rigueur devant une commission d'enquête
parlementaire
euh procéder à la prestation de serment
je vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et
je vais donc vous inviter euh et vous
pouvez le faire en même temps apprêter
serement de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité à lever la main droite et
à dire je le
jure merci
alors merci Monsieur P peut-être qu'on
je vais vous laisser vous
présenter chacun et chacune chacune et
chacun et puis après ce qu'on vous
propose c'est peut-être de faire un
déroulé liminire et ensuite on procédera
au à l'exercice des questions-réponses
je vous laisse présenter
mon bonjour Nathalie apéré REM président
de et secrétaire général de France
urbine Bonjour Éric Piol maire de
Grenoble et vice-président 2è
vice-président de
franceurb Monsieur Niel oui bonjour her
Niel représentant monsieuridier maire de
M et adjoint en charge de la
tranquillité publique merci merci ben
écoutez je je vous donne la parole et
puis ensuite le rapporteur prendra le
relais à l'issu de votre exposé liminire
allez-y bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci beaucoup
de nous avoir proposé cette audition
devant votre commission d'enquête comme
vous l'avez dit franurb a été à
l'origine d'une tribune signée par une
cinquantaine de Mair et élus locaux de
de grande ville euh dans euh la
diversité euh de nos appartenances
politiques de de nos points de vue une
tribune un peu inédite au regard de
constat partagés et d'une inquiétude
commune sur euh les questions de
narcotrafic alors au regard des
questions euh que vous avez bien voulu
vous nous adresser on vous propose euh
une présentation dans un premier temps à
deux voix avec erriic Kol euh je me
concentrerai plutôt rapidement sur la
question des constats partagés et Erol
et évoquera les pistes de réflexion
issues des travaux de la commission
sécurité de de Fran surven euh sur les
les constats partagés je pense que nos
formulations ne vous surprendront pas au
regard des des travaux que vous avez
mené si nous avons souhaité ensemble
alerter en septembre dernier
sur le caractère extrêmement préoccupant
de l'explosion du narcotrafic dans dans
nos villes c'est que nous avons nous
faisons tous le constat et
particulièrement depuis l'après covid
avec manifestement des choses qui se
sont accélérées à à ce moment-là d'un
narcotrafic qui est à la fois de plus en
plus important de plus en plus visible
de plus en plus
décomplexé dans ses méthodes de plus en
plus violent et qui nous le disons tous
dans nos villes et dans la diversité de
nos de nos territoires euh
gangraine de plus en plus de quartiers
mettent des habitants dans des
conditions de vie qui peuvent devenir
totalement insupportables à proximité
des des points de Deal et mettre ses
habitants
euh dans une exigence vis-à-vis des
institutions et y compris des des mares
que nous sommes quant au à leur qualité
de vie et aux conditions de de leur
sécurité donc quand on dit de plus en
plus présent de plus en plus violent je
je vous citerai pas ce que sont
notamment les effets en terme de de fait
d'homicide que qui ont déjà été porté
évidemment à à votre connaissance mais
315 faits d'homicide en en zone police
soit une augmentation de 57 % entre 2022
et et 2023 nous considérons que ça une
une
signification
particulière l'impression partagée
d'être passé de quelques points de ville
identifié à des quartiers entiers le cas
échéant sous sous emprise avec des
manifestations à la fois sur l'espace
public l'occupation abusive de l'espace
public l'appropriation de l'espace
public la mise sous pression des
habitants dans l'espace public mais
aussi sur des espaces privés pense en
particulier d'immeubles au parking euh
qui sont de fait des des espaces de plus
en plus euh utilisés sur la la
modification euh
de du DAL ou de la manière dont il est
exercé ce que nous notons aussi en
commun c'est le profil des trafiquants
avec dans chacune de nos villes des
constats faits par les autorités de
police sur des trafiquants de plus en
plus jeunes et et singulièrement euh des
mineurs et de plus en plus aussi
étrangers au territoire avec notamment
des filières
organisées
qui vont venir par les moyens diverses
de transport et de mobilité des jeunes
qui n'ont pas de lien particulier ni
avec la ville ni avec le quartier et et
qui de ce fait sont je dirais beaucoup
plus
difficile à appréhender y compris dans
dans une
logique non seulement d'interpellation
par les forces de l'ordre mais aussi le
cas échéant dans un un travail que nous
pouvons être amenés à faire de
prévention vis-à-vis de l'entrée dans le
trafic ce profil est beaucoup plus
compliqué à à cerner donc ça c'est sur
le
volet trafic sur les consommations
elles-mêm le constat aussi partagé par
les maires membres de notre association
d' unee très grande diversité des
produits très concrètement celles et
ceux qui étaient
essentiellement confrontés à du trafic
de cannabis voire de cocaïne voit
aujourd'hui sur la quasi totalité des
territoires euh l'émergence de produits
aux effets sanitaires beaucoup plus dur
euh le cque n'est pas uniquement un fléo
parisien le fintanille non plus parle
pas de protoxyde d'azote ou ou de
l'héroïne en tout cas une diversité des
des produits et de la même manière en
terme de santé publique mais aussi
tranquillité publique euh
des addictions qui conduisent à euh
des des comportements d'individus sous
substance de plus en plus incontrôlable
et
et à la fois de plus en plus malade et
plus en plus menaçant si si je prends le
volet santé publique d'un côté et le
volet tranquillité publique de l'autre
il est évident
que
la difficultés en terme de de santé
mentale et
d'addiction sont aussi visibles dans les
transports dans dans l'espace public
avec notamment des individus qui peuvent
être errants sur l'espace public et
complètement hermétique à toute approche
rationnelle et ayant complètement perdu
le sens commun des des rapports sociaux
et tout le monde a en tête ce que
peuvent être
des des situations comme celle-là et
quand une personne se présente nu dans
une rame de métro avec des seringues à
la main on peut imaginer ce que c'est
produit euh sur les usagers des des
transports publics et ça y compris dans
des villes qui n'y était pas confronté
l'ensemble des collègues font remonter
des des situations de de cette nature
alors sur notre rôle dans tout ça
puisque vous nous avez interrogé sur la
manière dont dont nous concevions la la
place des Maes il est évident que d'une
manière générale nous sommes animateurs
et fédérateurs
de différentes politiques publiques qui
euh
participe d'un lien
indirect de dans la lutte contre le le
narcotrafic avec bien évidemment des
politiques de tranquillité publique de
prévention de la délinquence de santé
publique de lutte contre les conduites
addictive de médiation d'éducation mais
aussi euh
d'aménagement on travaille de plus en
plus les uns et les autres sur la
prévention
situationnelle sur la manière dont
l'environnement urbain peut favoriser ou
au contraire lutter contre le trafic sur
la
rénovation
urbaine de de la même manière ça fait
partie des éléments qui sont intégré à
nos politiques publiques à la fois sur
le hard et sur le soft sur l'aménagement
de la ville en même temps
que sur la la
gestion
quotidienne nous sommes aussi animateurs
des stratégie de prévention et de de la
délinquence et de de sécurité en
situation de faire travailler ensemble
les les acteurs sur nos nos territoires
et alors je je vous livre le constat de
franceurben il y aurait sans doute des
témoignages pour
édulcorer sinon pour contredire mes
propos mais d'une manière générale le le
sentiment qui est le nôtre c'est que les
partenariats locaux fonctionnent bien
que notamment les liens
avec la police nationale et la plupart
du temps avec les autorités judiciaires
et singulièrement les procureurs sont
plutôt fluides nous avons des
CLSPD qui se déclin en de
multiples lieux et euh et instances de
de partenariat y compris au plus près
des quartiers dans les
GPO les les cellules de veille et d'une
manière générale le partenariat local et
l'envie de travailler ensemble sur ces
questions et quasi
systématiquement salué par les les
collègues Maes par ce qui n'empêche pas
de faire un certain nombre de constats
pour autant à la fois bien évidemment
sur les moyens dédiés de la police
nationale sur ces ces sujets et on y
reviendra sans doute mais on vous cache
pas que la perspective des Joos même si
elle réjouit tout le monde inquiète
aussi sur la disponibilité des forces de
l'ordre et des forces de police
singulièrement sur ces questions pendant
les mois ou l'année qui vient en en
réalité et puis au titre des
questionnements qu'il peut y avoir
également ce sont les moyens de la
police judiciaire les moyens de
l'enquête la durée des procédures nous
avons souvent des procureurs qui sont
très
impliqués ça n'empêche que la capacité à
faire de la justice est souvent
interrogée localement et d'abord et et
en premier lieu par les habitants parce
qu'on fait vivre nous aussi cette
relation entre les différentes
institutions et les habitants qui nous
demandent des comptes et qui nous
demande des comptes légitimement euh sur
la façon dont les institutions avancent
au vu de de ce qu'ils vivent et donc un
partenariat local qui fonctionne en
revanche une
inexistence totale de lien et de lieu de
travail entre nous et pour faire cours
les instances nationales ou ministère de
l'intérieur alors ça ça ne veut pas dire
que tel ou tel collègue ne va pas avoir
à un moment donné un rendez-vous ou un
travail avec avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur en revanche sur la la
dimension institutionnelle là où on a
mis en place des partenariats de travail
en France urbaine avec beaucoup de
ministres lorsqu'ils sont nommés ou en
tout cas de ministère nous ne parvenons
pas pour le dire très directement à
avoir un un travail satisfaisant avec le
ministère de de l'intérieur et nous ne
comptons plus les courriers sans réponse
les proposition de de travail nous avons
le sentiment qu'il n'y a pas de lieu qui
permettrait véritablement de reconnaître
les mairres comme des interlocuteurs
d'une politique de sécurité publique et
de lutte contre le le narcotrafic quand
bien même nous sommes clair sur nos
rôles et nos espaces il est évident que
nous ne pouvons être en en première
ligne et je viens sur les question de de
police
municipale nous sommes très attachés à
parce que chaque maire a la liberté de
la doctrine d'emploi de sa police
municipale dans le respect des textes et
de de la loi certaines sont armées
d'autres ne le sont pas les prérogatives
peuvent être différentes les missions
peuvent être différentes mais bien sûr
que la lutte directe contre le trafic de
stupéfiants
ou contre dans dans le cadre de
procédur judiciaire avec de
l'investigation en aucune manière ça ne
peut relever de nos polices
municipal elles peuvent concourir dans
leur mission de tranquillité publique à
la fois l'arrapopriation de l'espace
public mais aussi euh à pouvoir
notamment dans la pénalisation des
consommateurs le cas échéant en fonction
des doctrines locales intervenir euh
mais euh il nous semble que nous
resterons si nous voulons prendre toute
notre part nous avons euh évidemment la
conviction et la certitude qu'elle
restera résiduelle par rapport à des
organisations nationales et et
européennes mais éic Piol il il
reviendra euh voilà ce que sont
peut-être les éléments de de constat que
nous pouvions partager de de manière
plus directe sur quelques questions que
vous nous aviez adressé euh notamment
sur les phénomènes de corruption de
basse intensité ça ne fait pas partie
aujourd'hui des éléments qui remontent
ça pas dire que ça n'existe pas en tout
cas il y a pas de constat partagé sur
ces ces sujets et euh par ailleurs des
inquiétudes qui émergent sur deux sujets
directement liés et qu'il nous faut
peut-être aborder la question du
narcoterrorisme un certain nombre de
collègues se demandent jusqu'où peut
aller la violence décomplexée et à
partir du moment où la vie humaine n'a
plus de valeur ou de prix aux yeux de
certains trafiquants est-ce qu' qu' on
peut euh imaginer ce que sont ce que
serait des phénomènes de de cette nature
avec des opérations punitives
collectives et puis l'autre élément
avOcatiOn plus lutte contre la
délinquence financière et et
narcobanditisme ce sont les inquiétudes
qui sont les nôtres notamment sur le
blanchiment les réseaux de blanchiment
et de dissimulation en pensant notamment
à à la question des commerces de façad
alors qui s'ils ne sont pas constatés
sur l'ensemble des territoires que nous
représentons dans leur diversité y
compris démographique et et géographique
euh sont en revanche de plus en plus
présents et puis un dernier point sur
euh comment est-ce que ce phénomène
c'est généralisé en fait ce que l'on
constate c'est que certaines à notre
niveau euh certaines villes étaient déjà
confrontées depuis longtemps à
l'existence d'un milieu et de trafic
d'autes presque pas ou pas du tout mais
le le sen sentiment d'une accélération
et de convergence qui fait que aucun
territoire n'est à l'abri et que y
compris certaines villes qui étaient peu
concerné je pense par tropisme
géographique à l'ouest du pays notamment
parce que on était plus loin aussi d'un
certain nombre de marchés ça veut pas
dire qu'il y avait pas de la
consommation mais que les points
d'entrée étai le cas échéant
sensiblement différent et bien
précisément ce sont des territoires où
il est plus facile de s'implanter parce
qu'il y a moins de concurrence euh
et moins de réseau institués ce qui fait
que le sentiment d'une accélération est
extrêmement présent et des phénomènes
que nous ne connaissions pas du tout il
y a encore 3 à 5 ans sont en explosion
sur un certain nombre de de villes qui
ne les observaient pas jusqu'àors d'où
cette cette convergence des des constat
voilà pour cette première partie en en
laissant la parole à à er
bonjour mesdames et messieurs peut-être
pour prolonger donc le partage des
réflexions de franceurbaine plutôt sur
la partie piste de
réflexion avant que nous puissions avoir
un un échange libre
euh il nous semble que il serait
pertinent de d'avoir une évaluation
approfondie des dernières actions
régaliennes qui ont été entreprises sur
sur le sujet et que l'on puisse ainsi
établir des critères quels sont les
critères sur lesquels nous voulons
évaluer notre action en matière de
sécurité mais également en matière de
santé publique en matière d'occupation
de nos forces de de police de la justice
et cetera et que l'on puisse ainsi
construire un véritable plan national de
de lutte contre le trafic de drogue avec
évidemment des
réflexions
extra territorial vu l'ampleur du
phénomène le deuxième point sur cette
partieel là et c'est qu' nous semble
qu'il y a euh une nécessité d'avoir une
attention particulière des pouvoirs
publics pour ce qui se passe en outrem
puisque les départements et régions
d'outremer notamment Guadeloupe
Martinique guyen sont sont utilisés
comme des plateformes relais euh entre
la production de drogue et son
acheminement vers l'Europe et euh que
cela donne lieu à une hausse de violence
extrêmement forte des usages d'armes à
feu également extrêmement fort et
également une concentration de de
pratiques addictives en hausse dans les
centres-villes et il y a là un besoin de
coordination réelle entre la RS l'ofast
les préfectures les associations le
parquet les collectivités territoriales
les intercommunalités l'école mais il y
il y a vraiment une approche systémique
en plus de ce que peut faire police
nationale et et
gendarmerie
euh pour prolonger la la réflexion sur
l'évaluation
même si nous sommes bien conscients
qu'il y a des problématiques qui sont
spécifiques à la
France nous pensons que il faudrait
établir un travail de comparaison avec
ce qui est fait ailleurs notamment avec
des pays comme le Portugal qui ont été
pionniers quand quand à la dépéalisation
de la consommation et à la détention de
drogue ou aux États-Unis qui vivent vous
le savez une crise des opioïdes
absolument sans précédent et absolument
terrible dans un grand nombre de villes
et qui pour nous nous fait peur
clairement nous voyons tout ce qui se
passe autour du Fantan Hill aux
États-Unis et nous craignons que si ce
ces drogues extrêmement addictives sont
importées en France on se retrouve avec
le même genre de
situation dans dans nos villes donc ce
travail de comparaison pourrait être
croisé avec un une réflexion citoyenne
qui puisse pourrait être une convention
citoyenne telle que celle qui a portée
sur le climat ou une convention telle
que que porté par le CZE euh mais en en
tout cas un travail de comparaison et de
réflexion
citoyenne euh nous sommes évidemment
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du droit local
c'est dans ce cadre-là que nous agissons
nous au quotidien euh dans ce cadre là
euh nous soulignons l'importance de
simplifier le cadre juridique dans
lequel interviennent les policiers
municipaux euh parce que nous voyons le
risque que ces policiers municipaux
soient de plus en plus appé euh par les
nombreux faits euh de liés au trafic de
drogue ils sont souvent les premiers
intervenants les premiers sur le sur les
lieux euh parce que la police nationale
ou la gendarmerie n'ont pas le temps de
tout faire et euh ça fragilise euh
l'action publique sur le la délinquence
du quotidien cette petite délinquence du
quotidien qui elle euh est on dire le
souci euh premier de l'ensemble des
habitants hein il y a des habitants qui
vivent sur des PO point deal qui vit des
situations extrêmes vraiment
extrême et il y a le reste de la
population qui finalement ne voit pas
trop cette parti là il en entend parler
à la télé dans les journaux mais il ne
la voit pas trop et
qui ce reste de la population est
attaché à la délinquance du
quotidien donc voilà nous réfléchissons
sans avoir de
propositions totalement défin à ce stade
mais comment les policiers municipaux
pourrai avoir un un cadre expérimental
de manière limitée pour pouvoir
généraliser la verbalisation immédiate
dans le cas de de délit du quotidien ou
pour pouvoir opérer des contrôles
étillométriques pour pouvoir
éventuellement procéder à un contrôle
visuel des bagage de de quelqu'un et
cetera il y a là peut-être une
simplification qui permettrait
d'acter la répartition du travail qui
est de plus en plus faite vu absence de
moyens de la police nationale et le le
glissement des des responsabilités des
uns et des
autres un autre champ de nos réflexions
c'est la pénétration de ce trafic
dans notamment les commerces he comment
pouvons-nous lutter contre les commerces
de façade c'est une réflexion que nous
avons toutes et tous y compris
d'ailleurs pour nous-même quand on se
rend dans un commerce on aimerait savoir
si c'est un commerce qui est clean ou
pas donc ça fait partie de nos soucis du
quotidien quand on va se mettre dans un
café Ben qui est le propriétaire quels
sont ses liens c'est c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui nous prend la tête je
dirais euh et donc n nous souhaiterions
là avoir des des outils plus d'outils à
disposition des mes pour pouvoir lutter
contre les commerces de de
façades il y a différentes réflexions
qui ont été évoquées par la commission
sécurité et prévention de franceurbain
euh autour du contrôle du du travail
dissimulé autour de euh la révision
aussi des des plans locaux d'urbanisme
ou la formation à la culture de la
légalité pour les commerçants ou la
capacité de préempter des des beaux
commerciaux dans des périmètres de
sauvegarde euh qui voilà qui puissent
derrière nécessiter une autorisation
pour ouvrir un commerce avec certaines
clauses permettant ainsi à la police de
réaliser des des contrôles euh bref nous
avons
là un enjeu euh qui pour lequel nous
nous n'avons pas de solution toute faite
mais qui nous semble important parce que
nous craignons cette capillarité avec
les commerces qui ont opignon sur
ru 6e axe de de
réflexion
nous avons un un grand besoin de
d'accompagner de d'être accompagné plus
fortement dans les expérimentations que
nous pouvons faire notamment par par
exemple dans le travailvec Laam DK c'est
le cas agronome mais c'est le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres villes nous avons ça
nous a permis de produire des des vidéos
euh sur à destination des consommateurs
pour leur montrer l'envers du décor et
et ce à quoi il participent et là
cette ce travail est à 1000dk devrait
s'intensifier très fortement pour
pouvoir avoir une réelle euh stratégie
interministérielle de mobilisation
contre les conduites addictives puisque
un de nos axes de réflexion c'està dire
que nous parlons toujours du trafic et
c'est ça qui occupe l'espace public le
trafic c'est nuisance les luttes entre
gang et cetera mais finalement nous
parlons très peu en France des conduites
addictives et de stratégie de prévention
et de lutte contre les trafics
addictives donc ces plans reste à des
champs d'expérimentation qui sont
souvent très riches mais nous demandons
à être fort ement accompagné sur ce
planl
enfin un dernier axe de de proposition
est le le rapprochement des procureurs
de la République avec les élus locaux
avec
là demande d'un d'un service territorial
pérenne dédié au démantellement des
réseaux donc c'est fait à certains
endroits comme chez nous mais clairement
il y a une une attente là qui permett
d'avoir une cellule pérenne et de dans
cette cellule péren d'aborder également
les questions de récidives
puisqueaujourd'hui notre système
carcérale produit ou n'empêche pas je
sais pas comment il faut le dire
euh de la récidive et que nous nous
retrouvons ave une situation paradoxale
avec à la fois une des politiques les
plus répressives d'Europe en matière de
lutte contre les stupéfiants et à la
fois une situation qui non seulement ne
s'améliore pas mais a tendance à à se
dégrader et donc une situation qui qui
pour nous est extrêmement préoccupante
et quand nous pensons à situation
dégradée ça rejoint le la partie du
constat que faisait Natalie apéré sur le
fait que nous voyons maintenant euh un
certain nombre de nouvelles pratiques à
la fois géographique avec du déport des
des lieux de trafic dans des villes
moyennes ou dans des villages euh où les
les trafiquants se sentent plus protégés
ou une une professionnalisation on va
dire de des des services de cons aux
consommateurs de drogues en matière de
marketing de livraison de de rotation
des salariés hein il y a une dizaine
d'années en des
salariés des délinquants
euh il y a une dizaine d'années nous
voyons des premières stratégie était que
les dealers faisaient tourner les les
chouffeurs là les jeunes qui surveillent
d'un quartier à l'autre pour que les
couper de leur lien à l'adulte mais
maintenant nous voyons même les les
hommes de main qui viennent d'ailleurs
donc c'est c'est presque c'est pour ça
que je parle de salari c'est que c'est
presque un marché de l'emploi qui se
structure avec des stratégies de
recrutement et des stratégie de de
déplacement du travail voilà c'est les
les SEP axes que nous avons travaillé au
sein de franceurbain et après nous
sommes évidemment à votre disposition
pour échanger sur les questions
spécifiques merci beaucoup madame le ma
monsieur le ma est-ce que Monsieur Niel
à ce stade a des éléments
complémentaires à apporter
alors bonjour d'abord bonjour à tous
donc des éléments complémentaires bien
sûr que au niveau de la ville de mes
nous partageons et le maire de mes
partage totalement les conclusions et
les informations qui ont été données moi
je pourrais vous apporter effectivement
l'exemple d'une ville qui est une ville
j'allais dire qui est au cœur d'un
trafic puisque c'est une ville frontière
avec la Belgique qui dit la Belgique dit
la Hollande donc une une descente très
facile et des réseaux très structurés
pour venir sur la pour venir sur la
France donc mes est une porte d'entrée
par la Belgique une porte d'entrée par
l'Allemagne et en même temps j'allais
dire une porte de sortie puisque nous
avons du trafic qui remonte de l'Espagne
qui arrivve sur mes et qui sont
dispatchés à partir de là donc je ne
sais pas si c'est le moment euh sur le
sur le partage sur les les les j'allais
dire les constac qui ont été fait bien
sûr nous partageons sur les deal nous
avons vu l'évolution ici très claire des
du trafic un trafic qui était comme ça a
été souligné à la limite un trafic avec
une organisation locale qui devient de
plus en plus qui s'ouvre de plus en plus
sur le département j'allais dire et sur
la la périphérie sur la périphérie de la
ville un trafic qui a toujours ici quand
même été organisé à à l'international
entre guillemets puisque c'est une porte
d'entrée je le répète euh effectivement
des jeunes de plus en plus jeunes
impliqués dans les trafics c'est le
constat qui a été fait nous nous le nous
le partageons des jeunes étrangers au
territoire oui de plus en plus alors pas
sur un marché de l'emploi j'allais dire
national mais au moins régional au moins
local ça c'était c'est incontestable et
puis sur tout et c'est le plus
dramatique une montée de la de la
violence un trafic de plus en plus
violent des trafiquants qui n'ont plus
de limite nous avons connu à mes donc
ville moyenne de 120000 habitants que
l'on aurait pu croire relativement
épargné nous avons connu des j'allais
dire des règlements de compte et des
interventions avec des armes des armes
de guerre des armes lourdes et là je
dois signaler et je reviendrai peut-être
tout à l'heure euh la j'allais dire la
coopération avec la police nationale
puisque bien sûr la police municipale
n'a aucun j'allais dire aucun pouvoir
dans ce domaine donc on on constate sur
le trafic qui qui est qui est fait sur
une une ville moyenne de 120000
habitants certes avec des particularités
villes frontières
euh de j'allais dire de plus en plus de
violence de plus en plus de trafiquants
jeunes euh de plus en plus de d'ailleurs
de recours à la population le recours au
nourrices le recours aux appartements où
on cache où on se réfugie donc là aussi
ce qui nous amène nous à avoir une
réflexion sur le travail avec les les
organismes sociaux et notamment les les
les logeurs qui sont c'est important
d'avoir de travailler avec eux donc
voilà un petit peu sur le deal très
rapidement ce qu'on pouvait en dire euh
un deal qui a aussi évolué puisque
maintenant euh on a on arrive à avoir
des livraisons à domicile c'est-à-dire
que on a un point de deal on passe la
commande et soit on vient chercher la
marchandise soit la marchandise est
louée et c'est là où là aussi le rôle de
la police municipale est important sur
la surveillance de la de la circulation
aux abords des points de Deal et
notamment des scooters qui partent et
qui livrent sur l'ensemble sur
l'ensemble du territoire voilà alors
ensuite
euh si si je continue sur la
consommation évidemment une évolution
ici aussi sur sur une ville comme mes
sur la diversité des produits nous
n'avons plus un seul produit nous avons
tous les produits qui sont sur mess et
tout à l'heure on parlait de de crack
c'est assez dramatique parce qu'on voit
arriver des drogues extrêmement dures
sur des territoires où elle n'étaient
pas jusque jusque là alors bien sûr avec
les problèmes d'addiction les problèmes
de santé de mental la multiplication des
hospitalisations d'office
hospitalisation d'office donc qui
reviennent effectivement au maire et et
qui dans beaucoup de cas sont le fait de
consommation de de drogue sonans le fait
d'individu en herrance sur la voie
publique d'individus
effectivement difficile à j'allais dire
à gérer voilà alors après dans le rôle
dans le rôle effectivement de de des des
municipalités bien sûr le rôle de
coordination des actions publiques le
rôle est primordial des maires sur la
comment dire sur la politique de
prévention puisque nous restons
persuadés que c'est par là qu'on
arrivera à trouver des solutions on les
trouvera dans les politiques
effectivement de de sanction de
répression mais il faut absolument
travailler sur des individus qui bien
souvent sont des individus qui sont à la
fois victimes et à la fois euh
trafiquant à la fois coupabl donc là
aussi rôle important je crois que on l'a
souligné le rôle du CLSPD des CLSPD ou
ou des CISPD est primordial puisque
c'est là que l'on réunit effectivement
les partenaires locaux
euh indépendamment j'allais dire des
réunions régulière et classique entre
police la police et justice les les
municipalités les préfectures participe
à leur à leur façon effectivement à
leors avec leurs moyens euh bien sûr
mais euh surtout euh j'en viens là au
rôle de la police municipale euh ça a
été évoqué par Monsieur Pol mais
effectivement euh je pense que euh un
certain nombre de j'allais dire de pas
de mission mais de de pouvoir un petit
peu euh conforté pour les policiers
municipaux permettrait une meilleure
j'allais dire une meilleure approche de
de cette comment dire de ce contrôle du
du trafic du trafic de de stupéfiant euh
notamment effectivement les dépistages
la possibilité de faire des contrôles
des étillogi étilo étilyomètre pardon
des contrôles euh lors de contrôle de
de routier lors de contrôle d'initiative
c'est quelque chose qui manque
énormément le la verbalisation immédiate
le recours à l'amand forfaitataire
police municipale n'a pas le droit ne
peut pas avoir recours à l'amand
forfaitataire alors que ce serait un
grand j'allais dire un grand bon en
avant si on pouvait le faire ça
dégagerait les commissariats parce que
quand il y a des interpellations sur des
petites quantités et c'est souvent le
cas pour les polices municipales on est
obligé de présenter le le contrevenant à
l'officier de police judiciaire ce qui
prend du temps à tout le monde alors
qu'on pourrait traiter effectivement par
des amendes forfaitaire la le contrôle
d'identité je pense que si on
élargissait les possibilités de contrôle
d'identité aux policiers municipaux on
aurait effectivement beaucoup plus d'
d'efficacité donc il y a effectivement
pas mal on partage tout à fait le le le
constat qui a été fait de même que sur
les les commerces de façade les les
épiceries qui sont ouvertes toutes les
nuits ou quasiment toutes les nuits et
toute la durée de la nuit euh le
blanchiment d'argent qui
vraisemblablement et derrière ces ces
activités de façade donc sur une ville
moyenne comme une ville comme mes mais
avec une particularité d'être une ville
frontière
euh nous partageons totalement bien sûr
le le les constats qui ont été
faits merci beaucoup de cet exposé qui
était très complet le
rapporteur merci
beaucoup la police municipale se
caractérise par une proximité avec la
population elle connaît les rues elle
connaît les quartiers elle connaît
souvent les familles elle voit les
difficultés des uns et des autres et
cette police municipale elle peut être
utile dans deux domaines le premier
domaine c'est le repérage de la
consommation on sait que la consommation
c'est la base c'est un peu comme le vol
et s'il y a pas de receleur il y a pas
de voleur s'il y a pas de consommateur
il y a pas de trafic donc j'aimerais que
vous puissiez nous dire quel pourrait
être le rôle accru d'une police
municipale dans le repérage de la
consommation qui permet ensuite d'assoir
une politique de lutte contre le
trafic de même et c'est ma 2ème question
le trafic de drogue il se caractérise
par du blanchiment lutter contre le
blanchiment c'est lutter contre le
produit du trafic et c'est là que réside
l'essentiel de l'efficacité de l'action
publique qu'est-ce que peut faire la
police municipale et qu'est-ce que
peuTent faire les communes pour repérer
le blanchiment et lutter contre le
blanchiment alerter d'autres service
favoriser des saisies et favoriser le
COD échéant des confiscations est-ce que
sur ces deux domaines vous pourriez nous
donner quelques pistes je je vais
m'inscrire juste dans le dans la lignée
du du rapporteur pour vous poser une
question complémentaire un des
phénomènes
émergents qui nous a été décrit lors des
auditions publiques hein c'est le le
risque corruptif et la corruption de
basse intensité est-ce que dans ce que
vous appz de vos vœux sur une plus
grande latitude laissé aux police
municipales dans le travail avec la
police nationale sur le le trafic vous
ne craignez pas que ça expose les maires
à avoir à gérer ce risque corruptif qui
semble être une menace émergente dans le
pays qui démarre Nathalie tu veux mon
micro est coupé
je peux y aller aussi Bonz je démarre du
coup voilà voilà
pardon éteint le micro peut-être sur la
question du
repérage dire que nos polices
municipales sont en réalité déjà des
polices de renseignement et et que si
nous sommes attachés aux cellules de
veille ou au groupes
opérationnel qui permettent le partage
sur des situations territoriales mais
aussi sur des situations individuelles
c'est en étant convaincu
nos polices municipales qui sont comme
vous l'avez dit territorialisés qui ont
une nature de mission qui les mettent en
proximité avec les commerçants les
acteurs associatifs les les habitants du
quartier sont une une source de de
renseignement précieus pour la la police
nationale et les autorités judiciaires
ensuite et moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il y
a un rôle qui peut être retenu en dehors
d'une évolution législative
règlementaire c'estàdire qu'on le fait
déjà peut-être que je me trompe mais je
je vois pas très bien en quoi on aurait
besoin d'un texte qui nous dirait de le
faire davantage on n'est pas empêché sur
ces missions là on n'est pas empêché
pour l'ilotage on n'est pas empêché et
on a les canaux qu'il faut pour remonter
l'ensemble des des informations sur le
blanchiment c'est sans doute un peu plus
complexe et
euh et HERV pétron mais euh là pour le
coup euh on est tenu au pouvoir de
police du maire euh et les pouvoirs de
police du maire ils sont euh quand même
d'abord et avant tout sur ce champ-là
euh Hygiène Sécurité accessibilité euh
et et la capacité de contrôle de
l'activité elle-même c'est-à-dire qu'on
a à la fois euh pas de pouvoir
d'investigation sur ce que serait la
comptabilité
de l'établissement et et la vérification
des avoirs ou des des situations
fiscales et et je ne crois pas qu'il
soit souhaitable que nous l'ayons c'est
nos policiers sont pas formés pour ça
ils savent pas faire ça et et on serait
bien incapable de de donner des suites
opérationnelles à cette dimension là
donc sur ce sur ce volet là et puis
ensuite le volet
sanitaire au
sens V du terme s'il s'agit par exemple
de commerce d'alimentation on est aussi
assez assez dépourvu donc autant sur des
actions de prévention comme les
décrivait Erol sur des capacités de
droit de de
préemption élargie sur euh la manière
dont on peut utiliser peut-être mieux
euh nos nos pouvoirs réglementaires et
nos pouvoirs de police pour le faire euh
mais il y il y a des champs sur lequels
on sera on sera démuni et et encore une
fois sur la corruption on reste
évidemment euh
vigilant mais je je crois d'une manière
générale que euh les les maires euh se
pose clairement euh dans le débat public
partout sur nos territoires comme les
ennemis numéro 1 du des du deal et des
dealers que ça puisse exposer le cas
échéant c'est certain nous sommes
habitués à une forme de
conflictualisation des rapports sociaux
moins à une forme de risque direct mais
partout où nous allons je crois pouvoir
dire les uns et les autres dans les
quartiers et y compris parfois sous la
menace c'est pour dire la détermination
à à combattre alors encore une fois il y
aura peut-être des des situations et si
vous avez été alerté sur ces phénomènes
de de corruption c'est qu' il nous faut
y être particulièrement vigilant mais le
le message de l'association est celui
d'une
détermination publique totale en
audition au Sénat comme dans chacun de
nos quartiers
ou peut-être quelques réflexions
supplémentaires sur le repérage de vous
avez parlé de repérage de la
consommation je sais pas si c'est ça que
vous vouliez dire ou c'est repérage des
lieux de euh s'il s'agit de repérage des
lieux de Deal B nous avons cette
cartographie he elle est connue que ce
soit d'ailleurs par notre police
municipal ou nos agents en général ou
les élus directement puisque nous
sionons en permanence la ville et entre
les services de propreté urbaine les
services d'espace vert les services de
police municipal les élus et les agents
de de terrain en pratique nous avons une
cartographie à peu près live en direct
de des points deal
et nous faisons remonter donc les liens
de d'information se passent très bien et
de façon générale sont très fluides donc
le travail sur l'optimisation des moyens
de l'information en tout cas en ce qui
concerne la remontée la redescende c'est
différent et se fait si vous parlez
effectivement des repérages de lieux de
consommation puisque c'est le terme que
vous avez employé là la question est
vers qui se tourner est-ce que on parle
de la consommation dans la rue ou est-ce
que on parle de la consommation dans
l'espace privé et le repérage c'est
évidemment compliqué puisque on estime
je CIS qu'il y a un Français sur trois
qui consomme du cannabis donc votre
enceinte on l'a vu ces derniers mois
n'est pas exempte donc voilà il faudrait
décider à ce moment-là qui est ciblé en
matière de consommation est-ce que en
matière d'exemplarité on va par
exemple cibler les les élus est-ce qu'on
va cibler les profession libéral que
nous voyons nous voyons les les
véhicules s'arrêter sur les points de
Deal donc qui on va va ciblé en terme de
consommation et là ça pose évidemment la
question de quel est l'objet de cette
politique publique euh voilà donc je
pense ça montre juste que nous avons un
problème qui est que nous parlons que de
répression mais nous parlons pas de
santé publique hein et et aujourd'hui
cette question de la santé publique nous
nous frappe durement elle nous inquiète
nous en tant qu'élu quand nous passons
devant des collèges et des lycées le
matin et que nous voyons des des jeunes
fumés euh elle nous inquiète tout autant
quand nous voyons des notables de la
ville qui
manifestement fréquentent également des
lieux de dille VO donc disons-le
clairement
euh sur le repérage contre le
blanchiment pas grandchose de plus à
dire que ce qu'a dit natthalie peré nous
avons souvent des des doutes ou des
indices parce que il y a des
indiscrétions des rumeurs sur qui
reprend quel commerce donc nous faisons
remonter ces informations mais là ça
nécessite des travails un travail
d'enquête extrêmement fort
et je ne crois pas que nous ayons à à
nous engager plus avant n ce que je
disais dans les propositions de France
urbain c'est plutôt des moyens pour
opérer des contrôles qui sont peut-être
relatifs à d'autres sujets mais qui pe
permettent parfois plus sûrement de de
gêner un commerce en tout cas les
stratégies que nous développons nous en
lien avec le la police ou ou la justice
sont plutôt d'essayer de toucher euh des
commerçants sur lesquels on a des doutes
certains mais pour lesquels les enquêtes
pourraient être longues les toucher sur
des questions sanitaires ou des question
de réglementation parfois pour donner un
exemple de jusqu'où on peut aller il y a
eu une fermeture administrative d'un bar
parce que il ne respectait pas la
réglementation relative à la la
protection des données sur son code sur
ses codes Wii donc c'est vraiment un
détail mais il était de notoriété
publique le patron était un un
délinquant notoire mais il n'y avait pas
de de fait établis pour cela
euh dans les les missions euh qui de qui
aujourd'hui sont affectées au police
municipale je je redis que il est
extrêmement important pour la population
l'attente de sécurité de la population
de ne pas se désengager plus avant de
notre rôle de gardien de la paix de
régulation de l'espace public et de
lutte contre la petite
délinquence et nous voyons toujours ce
risque de tout
mobiliser sur le trafic de drogue en
délaissant tout le reste puisquon y met
de plus en plus de moyens mais est-ce
que des moyens supplémentaires
permettront d'éradiquer le trafic donc
on voit bien que ça dépouillera le reste
de nos missions de moyens qui sont
importants mais est-ce que les moyens
supplémentaire euh permettront d'avoir
un résultat donc je crois qu'il est
important de de garder cela en tête de
même que nous pourrions revenir sur
votre remarque dire que les policiers
municipaux ils ont une connaissance fine
de la de la ville il fut un temps pas si
lointain où les policiers nationaux
avaient une connaissance fil de la ville
connaissance des rues connaissance des
des acteurs des commerçants et cetera
c'était j'ai j'ai grandi moi voisin
direct d'un commissariat les policiers
nationaux qui étaient là connaissaient
parfaitement la ville connaissaiit
parfaitement les acteurs et maintenant
c'est sûr que comme ce n'est plus que
des polices d'intervention ils n'en
connaissent que des petites parties et
et donc ils n'ont plus ce maillage fin
mais ce maillage fin du coup il est
opéré par les polices municipales euh et
puis peut-être un un dernier point vous
avez vu qu'il y a eu un mouvement là des
des policiers municipaux
euh euh ce mouvement il est lié au fait
que ils voient dans leur mission de plus
en plus de transferts d'activités de
transfert de de charges venant des
missions d'origine de la police
nationale et donc leur revendication
légitime c'est dire bah si nous faisons
le même travail nous voulons les mêmes
avantages et les avantages qui ont été
octroyés aux
policiers
nationaux ont été importants ces
dernières années donc eux ils ditent bah
nous aussi donc là aussi nous avons un
un petit
risque à la fois sur le recrutement he
ceux qui viennent dans les polices
municipales aujourd'hui n viennent pas
pour les mêmes raisons que ceux qui
s'engagent dans la police nationale en
terme de mission donc plus il y a fusion
il y avait rapport de la Cour de la Cour
des comptes d'ailleurs sur ce sujet il y
a 2 3 ans plus il y a fusion
d'émissions plus
évidemment il y aura formation d'un d'un
d'un corps hein qui aura les mêmes
revendications que celle de la police
nationale et aujourd'hui clairement les
collectivités ne sont pas du tout en
capacité de d'aller sur le les niveaux
de de salaire de rémunération de
d'avantage que peuvent avoir les
policiers nationaux hein ils sont des
agents des collectivités locales même si
nous voyons déjà un petit schéma qui
fait que nous sommes en concurrence les
uns avec les autres et que nous avons
une petite tendance tous euh à augmenter
un petit peu le régime indemnitaire dans
T ou telle commune en espérant faire
venir les policiers du voisin et puis ça
continue comme ça en tournant euh voilà
ce que je pouvais partager merci
beaucoup monsieur Niel vous avez des
élément sur les les questions qui ont
été posées par le rapporteur alors sur
les je voudrais rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire monsieur P euh qui je
pense que c'est très très important je
crois qu'il ne faut pas confondre la
complémentarité entre les polices police
nationale gendarmerie nationale et les
polices municipales avec leur absorption
en terme de mission parce
qu'effectivement on voit de plus en plus
glisser des missions de police nationale
vers les policiers municipaux pour des
raisons très simples et ce que qui a été
très bien dit par Madame apéré et
Monsieur Piol c'est tout simplement
parce que le manque d'effectif le manque
de moyens de la police nationale amène
effectivement à se retourner vers les
polices municipales et c'est vrai
notamment dans le dans la proximité et
c'est important les polices municipal
sont des polices de proximité ce sont
des polices qui ont le contact et qui
doivent avoir le contact et qui l'ont
d'ailleurs avec leur leurs concitoyens
c'est un c'est une mission c'est une
j'allais dire c'est une approche qui a
été un peu perdu euh au fil des ans par
la police nationale et euh en terme de
trafic de stupéfiants il ne faut pas non
plus qu'il ait là aussi un transfert de
compétences ce serait la pire des choses
police municipales ne peuvent pas lutter
contre le trafic de de drogue elles
peuvent y participer effectivement et y
participer comme ça a été dit par leur
connaissance du terrain par leur
connaissance des habitants euh par le
fait qu'elles sont là alors dans
certaines communes H24 dans d'autres
pendant la journée ça peu importe mais
il y a une connaissance effectivement du
terrain il y a une connaissance fine
aussi des habitants mais ça doit pas à
mon sens ce repérage là j'allais dire à
la fois de la conso et des points de dal
euh ça passe aussi par les services
sociaux ça passe aussi par euh qui est
souvent dans les dans les villes en tout
cas ce qui est le cas à mes dans les mit
de quartier qui sont j'allais dire le
point d'entrée de beaucoup de
renseignements et qui permettent aussi
d'avoir un contact très proche avec la
population donc je crois que ça c'est le
rôle essentiel pour moi en tout cas des
polices municipales dans cette lutte
contre le trafic des des stupéfiants de
trafic de stupéfiants c'est
effectivement cette proximité cette
connaissance du terrain cette
connaissance du poil de dile comme
disait monsieur Pol on peut la suivre
j'allais dire presque heure après heure
parce que nous sommes sur le le terrain
et nous voyons ce qui se passe donc
après le problème c'est l'organisation
comment faire remonter efficacement et
rapidement cette information vers les
services concernés sur le sur le
blanchiment on est sur la même sur la
même logique nous connaissons
effectivement nous avons vend des
commerces qui sont entre guillemets
suspects donc là aussi et il peut y
avoir des surveillances ou des
attentions plus particulières sur ces
commerces il doit y avoir là aussi une
collaboration étroite une coopération
étroite avec police ou gendarmerie de
façon à passer ces informations qui
souvent d'ailleurs échappent à la police
nationale qui malheureusement a d'autres
tâches à d'autres missions et quand je
dis malheureusement d'ailleurs je me
reprends immédiatement peut-être
qu'effectivement il y a à repenser aussi
la le rôle des polices des polices
municipales mais attention sans sans
leur donner des missions qui ne sont pas
les leurs je crois qu'il faut qu'on
donne au policiers municipaux les moyens
d'accomplir leurs mission qui sont
essentiellement des missions de
proximité des missions de contact avec
la population donc forcément des
missions de
renseignement merci beaucoup alors j'ai
trois questions ici dans la salle Marie
Laur finera h ensuite Karine Daniel et
gu
bénaroche mer merci président bonjour à
tous alors j'ai juste deux petites
questions d'abord une question générale
à part cette une commune existe-t-il des
démarches pour regrouper les communes
grandes ou petites touchées par le
narcotrafic afin d'échanger notamment
avec les villes guyanaises d'où part une
partie de la drogue consommée dans vos
villes et une question particulière à
Monsieur Pol je sais que la ville de
Grenoble met en place de nombreuses
actions pour lutter contre le
narcotrafic mais Monsieur le Maire en
dehors de l'augmentation des effectifs
de police qu'attendez-vous de l'État
merci
alors bon peut-être sur la la
coopération et des villes de Guyane nous
n'avons pas d'échange spécifique sur des
échanges entre la Guyane et la France he
nous nous intégrons au sein de France
urbain c'est donc les les villes de plus
de 100000 habitants et les
intercommunalités de plus de 200000 ou
250000 corrige-moi natthalie je crois
que c'est 250000 euh donc qui regroupe
euh une centaine du coup de d'adhérent
entre ville et
intercommunalité nous avons une
commission donc notre principe c'est
évidemment la la rélexion transpartisane
et nous avons une commission qui traite
de ces sujets et qui
euh en tout cas depuis que je suis ma
depuis 10 ans est très consensuel sur à
la fois le partage du vécu il est
important pour nous de pouvoir partager
notre vécu qui est parfois un peu lourd
en ces domaine on a l'impression d'être
un peu à la fois très volontariste et et
démuni euh et et aussi de propositions
vous voyez que les propositions que nous
faisons sont effectivement assez
consensuelles et
transpartisanes voilà sur la deuxème
partie qu'est-ce qu'on attend de l'État
ben nous
attendrions dé critère d'évaluation sur
la stratégie de lutte contre le trafic
et narcotrafic mais aussi sur la
consommation pour nous ce qui nous
inquiète nous regardons aussi les
questions de santé publique
nous voyons
les l'explosion de la consommation nous
voyons celle du cannabis bien sûr qui a
un niveau extrêmement élevé mais
également ces dernières années une
banalisation de de la cocaïne et nous
vivons avec ce spectre de voir arriver
dans nos villes le crack le fantanil et
d'autres substance donc nous aimerions
une stratégie qui dise c'est quoi les
critères d'évaluation d'une bonne
politique de lutte contre la drogue en
prenant en compte toute la chaîne de des
questions de santé publique aux
questions de sécurité de sécurité liée
au trafic de drogue mais également de la
répartition des moyens entre cette lutte
contre la drogue et euh le reste des
phénomènes de violence que nous vivons
dans la société et que pour lesquels
nous sentons parfois un manque de moyens
euh voilà nous aimerions nousavons
répété Nathalie apéré le disait tout à
l'heure une transparence de la part du
ministère sur la répartition des
effectifs
euh on nous dit jamais quels effectifs
sont où donc nous avons toujours
l'impression d'être en concurrence les
uns avec les autres parce que tous
autant que nous sommes nous nous roulons
par terre devant le ministère de
l'Intérieur pour dire nous voulons nous
avons besoin une situation particulière
nous avons besoin d'effectifs
supplémentaires donc on nous octroie des
forces souvent bon c'est souvent une vue
de l'esprit puisque nous perdons en même
temps des effectifs qui partent donc on
nous annonce toujours des arrivées mais
jamais la balance net nous n'avons
jamais transparence communication des
chiffres et à chaque fois qu'on obtient
des policiers on se demande si on les a
pas piqué un collègue ce qui est pas un
sentiment très
agréable donc voilà un peu l'état
d'esprit dans lequel nous sommes nous
aimerions une politique plus pragmatique
et et puis nous voyons
l'évolution un peu cette de cette
balcanisation du trafic et avec une
montée en en puissance d'une violence
gratuite et soudain et et donc ça c'est
évidemment inquiétant aussi hein il y a
évidemment la recruesence de domicide
qui a eu l'année dernière parfois il y a
des temps morts on sait pas pourquoi à
Grenoble il y a eu je crois que 4 ans
entre 2016 et 2020 dans laquelle il y a
pas eu domomicide VI à la drogue mais en
fait on sait pas pourquoi on sait pas si
c'est parce que il y a un un patron
dealer qui tient bien tout le monde ou
au contraire si c'est parce que bon
c'est les alas et purement
de de la chance mais nous avons toujours
peur aussi d'une balle
perdue ça arrive très rarement mais
c'est évidemment la crainte de n'importe
quel acteur public quand nous voyons
maintenant des armes euh sortir en
pleine journée et et dans des lieux très
fréquentés donc euh voilà c'est nous
vivons avec ça et nous avons le le
sentiment désagréable que les les
politiques sont des politiques beaucoup
d'annonce et d'affichage euh ministre de
l'intérieur après ministre de
l'Intérieur depuis une vingtaine
d'années et que la situation a plutôt
tendance à se dégrader à la fois sur les
questions de santé publique et et les
questions de d'emprise et de ce que
subissent les habitants là où se passe
euh le trafic de drogue voilà pour ça
que nous avions pointé les éléments de
comparaison aussi quelques éléments de
comparaison objectif avec d'autres pays
et d'autres stratégies qui ont pu être
mises en place Karine
daniel Merci euh sur les les complémenta
entre les policiers municipaux et la
police nationale moi je pense que
vraiment c'est un un un élément sur
lequel il faut que nous ayons des des
points très précis parce que j'imagine
qu'il y a pas consensus dans les
différents territoires entre les
différentes équipe sur ce qui relève de
de la police municipale ce qui relève
des des policiers nationaux et et dans
quelle mesure parfois aussi parce qu'il
faut se dire les choses le fait de
donner plus de de missions à des
policiers municipaux peut générer
parfois un désengagement ou ou ou des
des des ajustements quant aux missions
des des policiers nationonau et et leur
déploiement ça c'est une remarque sur la
question moi je suis très attentive à ce
que vous avez évoqué sur la coopération
des villes et des territoires avec le le
ministère de l'Intérieur et est-ce que
cette demande que moi il me semble
important de de relayer qu' a évoqué
Nathalie apéré elle est notamment encore
plus nécessaire du fait de la plus forte
mobilité géographique des trafiquants et
du fait de de l'évolution toujours plus
importante des flux euh et et de leur de
de leur mobilité géographique je pense à
ce qui se passe en terme de d'évolution
des entrées par rapport aux dispositifs
qui sont mis en place dans les ports par
exemple qui modifi la la géographie des
trafic et qui modifie donc l'impact euh
sur les villes selon leur selon leur
[Musique]
situation peut-être sur votre remarque
madame la sénatrice sur la répartition
des missions police municipale police
nationale le point qui fait consensus au
sein de
l'association c'est que les polices
municipales restent sous l'autorité du
maire d'une part et que chaque maire et
chaque équipe municipale d'autre part
est libre dans le cadre du droit bien
évidemment des missions qui lui
affectent et et ça c'est ce qui nous
permet d'avoir ces propositions
transpartisanes parce que sinon il y a
effectivement euh des débats entre nous
certains considérant que le régalien ne
se partage pas et qu'il est dangereux
euh de d'aller trop loin ou encore plus
loin dans la substitution des polices
euh municipal enfin des polices
nationales au bénéfice des polices
municipales euh ça c'est des des
questions de de principe et puis euh
d'autres voyant qu'au contraire on est
confronté à ces pénuries ces difficulté
euh d'effectif et et je je le redis hein
parce que je je me permets de le noter
dans la perspective des Jos euh une une
inquiétude qui est accrue pour les les
mois qui viennent et d'autres se disant
que euh finalement euh il peut euh être
concevable que des polices municipales
puissent devenir plus fortement
auxiliaire euh des des polices
nationales dans le cadre des conventions
mais ce qui est important pour nous
c'est qu'on soit dans le cadre d'un
choix d'une équipe municipale et non pas
de mission qui soit imposée par l'État
aux polices municipal parce que après
nous rendons des comptes devant les
habitants et si les habitants
considèrent que les positionnements de
tel ou tel d'entre nous ne sont pas
adaptés il leur appartient de les les
sanctionner mais cette cette dimension
là est absolument essentielle sur la la
coopération avec le le ministère de
l'Intérieur oui nous nous la réclamons
de nos vœux et nous l'avons formalisé à
à différentes reprises je crois
d'ailleurs que notre tribune elle se
traduisait comme l'ensemble des
courriers que l'on produit euh comme
terminer par une main tendue
pour travailler coopérer essayer de
rechercher des solutions dans un cadre
global comme l'évoquait
ériol tout à l'heure
avec
véritablement le le sentiment et je je
veux insister
là-dessus encore une fois er le disait
tout à l'heure mais que on est en bout
de chaîne on est en bout de chaîne
avec un isolement des un et des autres
dans la réponse à la population
c'està-dire que ses réunions de quartier
ses interpellations quotidiennes elles
nous sont adressés et et c'est bien
normal parce que nous sommes à
disposition des des habitants pour cela
et il nous arrive souvent je le sais les
uns et les autres de dire si si c'est
juste parce que notre équipe municipale
ou notre police municipale ne s'occupait
pas du problème qu'il y en a un alors
dans le pays les choses iraient mieux et
la réalité c'est qu'on voit
effectivement qu'on est confronté
partout partout partout à des phénomènes
de de plus en plus dur et que ce n'est
ni en faisant des moulinets avec les
bras ni euh en quintuplant ou sextuplant
les moyens de police municipal le cas
échéant qu'on parviendra à à cette
approche qui passe aussi et si on évoque
le niveau européen euh par non seulement
des gels d'avoir financiers mais aussi
des contrôles aux frontières des
remontées de de filières des
coopérations interpolice ENF on voit
bien que c'est de tout ça dont on a
besoin en réalité pour combattre le
trafic et puis peut-être un petit point
d'ajout euh mais en en marge de de votre
question sur le fait que on conçoit
cette lutte euh y compris en dehors du
rôle strict de la police municipale
c'est-à-dire que les les propositions
que nous portons sont pour certaines
liées à la police municipale pour
d'autres pas du tout parce que notre euh
travail il est bien celui d'une approche
à à 360°r je vous citer euh un exemple
qui pourrait apparaître éconoclaste mais
la manière dont par exemple nos services
déchets euh ou propreté sont capables
d'accompagner une opération de police il
y a euh quelques opérations euh
d'ailleurs je crois ça a été théorisé au
plus haut niveau de l'État l'idée qu'il
y ait des interventions coup depoint de
nettoyage ou de pilonnage des des points
de de deal si elles sont régulières
chacun s'en réjouit mais euh si en
parallèle nos polices municipales sont
euh nos polices municipales nos services
pardon sont mobilisés pour saisir les
canapés parce que le le canapé euh c'est
souvent ce qui pour le quotidien des
habitants
symbolise ce qu'il y a de plus
insupportable dans un point de deal qui
occupe l'espace public au vu et auessus
de tout le monde avec beaucoup
d'incompréhension sur comment est-ce que
c'est possible si nos services sont
mobilisés en parallèle et qu'on est
capable de montrer bah voilà on a saisi
tant de canapés tant de sièges et et
voilà comment ça va nuire concrètement
au trafic c'est peut-être enfin c'est un
roule qui est pas celui de la police
municipale qui est moins visible mais
mais qui concourt aussi à cette cette
stratégie et puis le l'autre élément
pour concourir à cette stratégie c'est
nos politiques de santé publique et
petit message sur les moyens des carudes
qui font les centres de consommation et
de réduction des des risques qui qui
font un travail extrêmement important et
et néanmoins restreint par les moyens
alors même que les situations de
toxicomanie avérée et pratique à risque
sont de plus en plus nombreuses
guénaroche
oui merci merci à vous
trois je vais juste parler d'une petite
précision demander une petite précision
dans dans dans ce que vous avez expliqué
tout à l'heure je crois que c'est Éric P
qui en a parlé tu as parlé Eric
d'accompagner des expérimentations de
ville par exemple concernant un certain
nombre de de de mesures concernant les
conduites addictives par exemple ou la
prévention alors je je voulais savoir si
si sur ce point-là euh vous avez
réfléchi et vous avez quelques un ou
deux exemples à donner justement
d'expérimentation dont vous pensez
qu'elle pourrait être généralisée ou en
tout cas étendue alors qu'elles sont
venu d'initiativ de certaines communes
isolées et quand tu parles
d'accompagnement de ces initiatives et
de ces expérimentations ériques je
voulais savoir en fait dans ces cas-là
qui pourrait vous accompagner et dans
quel cadre est-ce qu'il faut créer un
cadre d'accompagnement de ces
expérimentations est-ce que ça paraît
utile ou pas
voilà
h bon il y
a enfin de mon point de vue aujourd'hui
on en est pas un point où on se dit
tiens on a trouvé des expérimentation
queil faudrait généraliser
partout euh c'est plutôt des
euh
des bon des projets embryonnaires euh
qui débouchent nous on a travaillé là
pendant 2 ans avec des des groupes
d'habitants autour
de pour produire des vidéos qui ont été
financé par la M des cas euh pour
montrer l'envers du décor et donc
montrer la vie des habitants derrière un
point de Deal donc là la cible c'était
les consommateur c'était juste pour dire
que nous avons un un décalage très fort
dans la population
entre la consommation de drogue que tout
le monde trouve normale euh et euh la R
ité vécu euh au pied au pied des des
points de d'Al
avec des gens qui doivent s'excuser de
demander pardon pour rentrer chez eux ou
dans les cas les plus durs des gens qui
partent en vacances et qui reviennent
les sériux de leur appartement a été
changé et il y a une une copropriété ou
une colocation entre le le dealer et le
locataire de l'appartement propriétaire
de l'appartement qui devient nourrice de
force donc c'est c'est ça que nous
voulions montrer euh pour
euh enlever un peu de légèreté à cette
consommation de drogue que tout le monde
a l'air de trouver récréative euh nous
avons travaillé avec une pièce de
théâtre pour parler là aussi de la vie
euh dans le deal nous faisons des euh
sensibilisations au collège euh avec
notre police municipal pour sensibiliser
à ces questionsl et à plein d'autres
sujets hein évidemment mais mais pour
créer du lien euh à un moment où il y a
des risques forts de de tomber dans
l'argent facile et puis la
reconnaissance sociale le sentiment
d'appartenir voilà à à un groupe euh
pour venir lutter contre contre cela
donc c'est à la fois des éléments de
d'éducation populaire mais qui sont fait
avec des moyens extrêmement faibles hein
rit l'éducation populaire a été
complètement
cassée des moyens cassés ces moyens de
financement cassés euh et des
expérimentations pour plutôt cibler tous
ceux qui vivent bien en tant que
consommateur euh mais qui euh le font
sur le dos de leurs voisins euh du du
quartier d'à côté voilà donc rien de
magique est-ce qu'on a besoin d'un d'un
cadre d'accompagnement euh pas forcément
on a besoin de de financement et d'une
stratégie de prévention euh unee
stratégie globale en fait fait qui aille
de toute la chaîne qui démarre à la
prévention qui traite des problèmes de
santé et qui regardent des consommateurs
de drogue comme des malad et pas que
comme des consommateurs et créatifs ou
des délinquants et qui aillent jusqu'à
le travail pour éviter la récidive après
le passage en
prison Michel bonus
oui merci moi je sais pas en fait à qui
je je pose la question je voudrais juste
savoir si vous
aviez des données sur quand le le
système éducatif vous avez parlé là
quand le système associatif est fort
dans un quartier est-ce qu'on a le
sentiment que et la mobilisation forte
aussi on le sentiment que le trafic de
drogue
baisse et vous avez vous avez aussi
parlé d'éducation populaire revenu aussi
sur le le régalien ne se partage pas je
suis pas complètement d'accord parce que
sur l'éducation et sur la santé
souvent on le partage voilà et c'est
bien ce que sur sur l'expérimentation
c'est c'est le sens de ma question aussi
au sein d'une ville ou d'un département
euh on a vu ce qui s'est passé ce qui se
passe au Portugal vous l'avez souligné
vous
l'avez au début de votre où où on sent
qu'il a on sent qu'il y a une baisse une
baisse très significative du trafic et
et surtout de de la consommation est-ce
qu'on peut éventuellement l'envisager
donc mon premier volet c'est la
prévention sur la prévention essentiel
sur si on met l'accent sur l'éducation
la culture le sport est-ce que ça baisse
sur le sentiment que le trafic est moins
présent et après et après faire faire le
parallèle avec des pays qui ont qui sont
en face de réussir comme le Portugal où
on sent qu'il y a une vraie baisse et
que ils sont en dessous de moins 5 fois
la consommation sur le dans le continent
européen donc par rapport à notre pays
c'est quand même révélateur voilà
merci peut-êre dire un mot bon sur le
Portugal vas-y Nathalie
pardon non peu
importe parmi les les éléments qui font
consensus on peut le dire comme ça parce
que voilà on parle au nom de
l'association après chacun peut avoir le
le cas échéant ses ses
positionnement mais nous sommes capables
de dire ensemble nous avons la la
législation la plus répressive d'Europe
et pour autant la consommation la plus
élevée d'Europe parce que ça ce sont des
faits et c'est évidemment euh pour ça
que nous regardons avec beaucoup
d'intérêt euh le système portugais
quandbien même l'association ne se
positionne pas sur les questions de
dépénalisation ou de légalisation et par
contre appelle plutôt à la poursuite de
débat et y compris le cas échéant via
des des conventions citoyennes sur la
corrélation euh entre
euh éducation populaire euh force des
liens sociaux et euh point deal je je je
suis pas sûre qu'on dispose de constat
scientifiqu en la matière et ce dont je
suis persuadé en revanche et de ce dont
nous sommes persuadés euh c'est c'est
que
euh ces politiques doivent être menées
euh en tout état de cause euh qu'il y
ait ou non euh point de Deal et que
elles sont au bénéfice des habitants de
de toute façon euh qui plus est
lorsqu'il subissent des points de Deal
c'est-à-dire
que on voit bien qu'on est face à des
phénomènes qui sont d'une telle ampleur
que il pourrait y avoir un découragement
à mener certaines politiques d'éducation
de prévention de santé voire même
certaines politique de police qui ont
quelquefois pour effet de déplacer le
point deal parce qu'on est sur un marché
tellement organisé que
euh les droits se reprennent le cas
échéant à un autre endroit et et pour
autant tout ce qu'on aura pu faire au
bénéfice
de la lutte contre l'entrée dans le
trafic et notamment le travail avec les
parents l'occupation positive de
l'espace public l'amélioration du cadre
de vie c'est aucunement invalidé par le
fait que le cas échéant le point de de
lui se soit déplacé donc je pense qu'on
a vraiment besoin de mener les deux en
en parallèle mais considérant
aujourd'hui que le le niveau et c'est
pour ça qu'on parle vraiment de
narcotrafic et de narcobanditisme de
cette organisation criminelle est telle
qu'on a aussi besoin de moyens qui vont
excéder ce qu'on est capable de faire et
de manière indispensable et de plus en
plus sur le champ de la PR prévention de
la santé de
l'éducation y a-t-il
d'autres intervention sur ce
sujet bon je crois qu'on a épuisé les
questions de notre
côté vous reste-t-il des des
interventions ou des sujets que vous
souhaaitiez aborder c'est bon ben
écoutez il nous reste à vous à vous
remercier très chaleureusement du temps
que vous nous avez consacré à cette
commission d'enquête et puis on aura
l'occasion de euh revenir vers vous avec
nos notre rapport qu'on rendra euh début
mai merci beaucoup bonne journée merci
merci merci à vous bonne
journée